>> Laura: AS DEMOCRATS WORKED TO
CONCEAL THE WHISTLE-BLOWER AT
THE ROOT OF THIS IMPEACHMENT
SCAM, WE NOW LEARNED SHOCKING
NEW DETAILS ABOUT THE GENESIS OF
THE RUSSIA HOAX.
WHILE THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
SPECIAL GENERAL MIKE HOROWITZ
HAS EVIDENCE THAT AN FBI LAWYER
CHANGED A KEY DOCUMENT THAT LED
TO THE SURVEILLANCE OF FORMER
TRUMP CAMPAIGN ADVISER CARTER
PAGE THAT JOINS US NOW.
HIS FIRST APPEARANCE ON FNC.
CARTER, DO YOU FEEL VINDICATED
BY THIS NEWS?
>> IT'S MORE OF THE SAME, LAURA.
THESE PEOPLE KEEP SAYING THE
SAME INFORMATION.
WE'VE KNOWN ABOUT THIS HOAX FOR
SO LONG AND THE WRONGDOING.
UNFORTUNATELY, IT'S -- THERE'S
BEEN NO REAL ACTION TO ADDRESS
THESE ISSUES.
IT'S A POSITIVE, BUT IT'S NOT
ANYTHING, YOU KNOW, AMAZING.
>> Laura: CARTER, "THE
WASHINGTON POST" TRIED TO DOWN
PLAY THE INSPECTOR GENERAL'S
REPORTED FINDINGS SAYING THE
CONDUCT DID NOT AFFECT THE
OVERALL VALIDITY OF THE
SURVEILLANCE APPLICATION
ACCORDING TO U.S. OFFICIALS.
THE PERSON UNDER SCRUTINY IS A
LOW-LEVEL LAWYER THAT HAS BEEN
FORCED OUT OF THE AGENCY.
TO ME ULTRASOUNDED LIKE A
PREEMPTED LEAGUE.
SO BY THE TIME THE REPORT COMES
OUT, THEY'LL SAY OH, WE ALREADY
COVERED THAT.
IT'S ALL WATER UNDER THE BRIDGE
NOW.
DID THAT SURPRISE YOU TO HEAR
THE POST REPORT ON IT THIS WAY?
AGAIN, KIND OF -- YEAH, IT'S NOT
GOOD BUT IT DIDN'T REALLY AFFECT
THE VALIDITY OF THE UNDERLYING
WARRANT.
>> I'VE SEEN THIS COMING A MILE
AWAY.
THESE PEOPLE -- I HAVE HAD ZERO
INPUT.
I HAVE HAD PRIVACY ACT OF 1974.
I KNOW YOU'VE HAD PRIVACY ACT
ISSUES WITH THINGS THAT HAVE
BEEN DONE AGAINST YOU RELATED TO
THESE UKRAINE ISSUES.
UNFORTUNATELY I'VE HAD ZERO
INFORMATION.
THEY HAVE THIS BIG -- MANY
HUNDREDS OF PAGES OF A REPORT
AND I'VE HAD ZERO ABILITY TO
REVIEW ANY OF IT OR ASK FOR ANY
CORRECTIONS.
MEANWHILE, THESE SAME PEOPLE
APPARENTLY LEAKING ARE HAVING
ALL KINDS OF INPUT.
IT'S A COMPLETE DISASTER.
>> Laura: THE MUELLER REPORT,
EVERYONE HAS TO REMEMBER WHAT IT
STATED ABOUT YOU, WHICH PEOPLE
FORGET.
THE INVESTIGATION DID NOT
ESTABLISH THAT PAGE COORDINATED
WITH THE RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT IN
ITS EFFORTS TO INTERFERE WITH
THE 2016 PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION.
THAT SHOULD HAVE BEEN THE END OF
THE STORY.
I SAY TO EVERY AMERICAN WATCHING
TONIGHT, CARTER, THEY SEE YOU
TONIGHT ON TV.
BUT THIS COULD HAPPEN TO ANYONE.
IF THEY CAN TARGET SOMEONE WITH
ZERO BASIS BASED ON SET-UP
MEETINGS AND PHONY -- SAYING HI
TO SOMEONE AT A CONVENTION,
SUDDENLY YOU DIDN'T TELL US THE
TRUTH ABOUT THIS.
THEY DID THIS TO GENERAL FLYNN
AND TRIED TO DO IT TO YOU.
IT SENDS CHILLS DOWN MY SPINE
AND EVERYBODY ELSE WATCHING.
MAYBE THINK I'M BEING HYPERBOLIC
BUT I'M NOT.
>> YOU'RE UNDERSTATING IT.
THEY WEREN'T JUST SPYING ON ME.
THEY SPIED ON ALL THE PEOPLE I
TALKED WITH DURING THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN, DURING THE TRUMP
TRANSITION AND INTO THE EARLY
MONTHS THROUGH SEPTEMBER
APPARENTLY OF 2017.
SO ALL OF MY INTERACTIONS WITH
VARIOUS PEOPLE.
THEY SWEPT UP ALL OF THAT.
MEANWHILE, AS WE AGAIN SAW TODAY
IN THE ARTICLES YOU CITED,
THEY'RE JUST DEALING WITH THEIR
FRIENDS IN THE MEDIA AND
UNDERMINING THE PRESIDENT.
>> Laura: YOU WERE THE CONDUIT
OBVIOUSLY.
YOU WERE THE WAY TO GET AT
TRUMP.
THAT'S UNDERSTOOD.
BY THE WAY, THE GUY THAT "THE
NEW YORK TIMES" IS FLAGGING,
THEIR THEORY, KEVIN KLINESMITH
IS THE GUY THAT ALTERED THE
REPORT.
HE'S NOT FOUND -- BUT HE'S NOT
FOUND POLITICALLY BIASSED
ACTIONS BY FBI HIGHER UP.
HE WAS FLAGGED BEFORE FOR BIAS.
THIS SAME AGENT.SO HOW DEEP DOES
THIS GUY?
IF A LOW LEVEL GUY THINKS HE CAN
DO THIS, HE'S NOT GETTING
SIGNALS FROM THE HIGHER UPS THAT
IT'S KOSHER TO BEHAVE THIS WAY?
>> THIS IS HOW FAR WE ARE FROM
THE TRUTH RIGHT NOW.
I HAD COMMUNICATIONS WITH
MR. KLINESMITH IN EARLY APRIL OF
2017 WHEN ALL OF THESE CRIMINAL
LEAKS WERE HAPPENING.
YOU KNOW, ALL OF THESE PEOPLE
WERE TRYING TO UNDERMINE THE
PRESIDENT'S ADMINISTRATION.
AND TELLING HIM -- THE PRIMARY
THING I WAS ASKING FOR THE FBI
IS TO DEAL WITH THE DEATH
THREATS THAT I'M GETTING.
I FLAGGED THAT FOR HIM AND DID
NOTHING.
>> Laura: OF COURSE.
CARTER, I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE TONIGHT.
I'M SORRY FOR WHAT YOU'VE HAD TO
GO THROUGH FINANCIALLY, THE
CONCERNS ABOUT YOUR REPUTATION.
IT'S EVERYTHING.
SO MANY PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
UNFAIRLY TARGETED.
IT'S LIKE A POLICE STING